[Music]
what happens when you keep a peeled
banana out in the open the banana
gradually deteriorate and we find
several tiny creatures hovering over it
these tiny creatures are commonly called
fruit flies they're annoying right but
did you know that these small wonders
are one of the most powerful tools for
geneticists sounds hard to believe but
these fruit flies are used as model
organisms in genetics let me tell you an
extremely important and unbelievable
fact did she note that the common fruit
fly Drosophila melanogaster and humans
have genes that are almost 60% similar
to each other
Hieu heard me right just a total of
eight chromosomes in this tiny creature
contains around 60% genes similar to the
humans and not only this but the fruit
fly is also used as a model to study the
most serious neurodegenerative disorders
including Parkinson's and Alzheimer's so
this little creature is nothing short of
a miracle for us but who thought of
using these tiny model organisms for
experiments the use of Drosophila
melanogaster as model organisms dates
back to several years however the
organism rose to fame with the
experiments to the father of
experimental genetics Thomas Hunt Morgan
following Bovary and Sutton's
chromosomal theory of inheritance Morgan
and his colleagues carried out many
experiments on the common fruit fly
which served us further confirmation for
the theory let's have a look at what
experiments he actually performed and
what results he got for that let's
travel back in time and reach the early
years of the 20th century it was around
the early years of 1900s that Thomas
Hunt Morgan started working on fruit
flies put a determination to find
something new
did she really find something
interesting yes he did
one fine day in a vial containing
red-eyed flies Morgan found something
strange he could spot a male fly with
white colored eyes Morgan knew that this
is a special type of mutant and the
experiments with this will lead to a new
path in genetics so how did he plan his
experiments what was the procedure let's
find that out in the next part imagine
you're working in a lab with the little
fruit fly
one fine day you find an unusual mutant
among the other wild types the wild type
means the ones normally found in nature
or the natural forms to be precise so
the mutant form means the ones that have
undergone some random or unusual changes
for example red eye color is the natural
or wild type of variety in fruit flies
but the white eye color is a mutant form
so what would you do if you find a
mutant type of fruit fly in a vial one
day I am sure anyone would simply grab
the opportunity and begin experimenting
with this unique variety the father of
experimental genetics Thomas Hunt Morgan
was not an exception to this one fine
day he found a unique mutant in one of
his vials while working in the lab the
mutant was a white-eyed male fruit fly
soon he realized that the exclusive
mutant was an ideal model for carrying
several experiments that would lead us
to new paths in genetics let's begin
understanding how Morgan carried out his
famous experiments on the fruit flies
which later proved the chromosomal
theory of inheritance better
Morgan crossed the white-eyed male with
a wild-type that is a red-eyed female
the f1 generation had all the offsprings
with red
eyes this showed that red eye color is a
dominant trait okay so what's next then
Morgan stepped ahead to cross the f1
hybrids what he expected was a three to
one ratio that is what we get in the f2
generation right
and what should the genotypic ratio be
it should be one to two to one and is
this what Morgan obtained yes Morgan
obtained three red-eyed flies and one
white eyed fly in the f2 generation also
the genotypic ratio was one to two to
one these results suggest that Mendel's
experiments were correct kind of Mendel
had obtained ratios for plants here we
considered animals for the experiment
that is why although Morgan had obtained
the ratios just like Mendel did things
didn't end here Morgan
obtained only one white eyed fly in the
f2 generation but note that this fly is
a male this unfolds a lot of hidden
ambiguities
why didn't he obtain a white eyed female
did this hint at something that's a
right guess the results not only gave a
proof of the chromosomal theory of
inheritance but also helped in shining
light on newer concepts Morgan assumed
that the eye color genes that are passed
down the generation are sex-linked now
what could this be
let's get introduced to this term first
we know that chromosomes in organisms
are of two parts one type is called
autosomes which are simply not the sex
chromosomes and the second category is
the sex chromosomes themselves which
determine the sex of the organism these
chromosomes are usually represented with
the letters X and y in most all
individuals with X chromosomes are
females while individuals with One X and
one y are males getting back to our
concept sex-linked implies the
characters or traits linked to the sex
chromosomes so the characters which
usually pass down the generations with
respect to a particular sex will be sex
linked so in this case Morgan did not
stop at the fact that his results
confirm the chromosomal theory he went a
step ahead and put forth the assumption
that the genes for eye color are present
on the X chromosome in the fruit fly in
the next part let's understand what
Morgan had to say about this we are in
the midst of studying Tomas Morgan's
experiment we have seen so far that
Morgan crossed a white-eyed male with a
red eyed female which is the wild-type
the f1 generation had all the offsprings
with red colored eyes also when he
obtained the f2 generation
it made him assume that the genes for
eye color are present on the X
chromosome in the fruit flies now to
understand this better let's carry out a
theoretical cross to begin with let's
denote the chromosomes as x and y for
representation purposes but if we use x
and y to represent the chromosomes then
how do we represent the genes on these
chromosomes for that we will write
additional letters in superscript so
let's say we write the letter W in
lowercase to represent the genes for
white colored eyes the red eyed
phenotype will then be represented by
the letter W in lowercase having a plus
sign after it do you think this
representation is strange well that's
how it's usually done in genetics the
first letter of the mutant type is used
for denoting the alleles
hence we use the letter W for
representing the mutant allele for white
eyes we simply add the plus sign to it
to denote the wild-type so instead of
using the letter R for red eye color we
use W plus also we need to know that the
wild-type which is the red eye trait is
dominant over the mutant type which is
the white eye trait getting back to the
experiment
Morgan assumed that the genes for the
trait are present on the X chromosome
let's also assume the same and begin
crossing and see if we get the same
results so we have the X with W in lower
case for representing the genes that
give white colored eyes and we have X
with w+ for representing the wild-type
that is the red colored eyes now we
begin the crossing of the white-eyed
male with the red-eyed female the cross
yields all the offsprings with red eyes
in the f1 generation this is how the
genes are passed to the progeny now the
next step is crossing the offsprings
from this f1 generation on crossing
these two with red eyes we get a progeny
that is in the ratio 3 to 1 so we've got
3 that are red eyed and 1 that's why
tied to be precise we obtain one male
with red eyes and two females which are
red eyed the only white eyed fly is this
male here if you remember Morgan
obtained this same result so this
assumption that we made give us the same
results as the Morgans cross
hence the assumption that the genes for
eye color were present on the X
chromosome in fruit flies is correct now
what if the alleles would have been
present on the y chromosome then the
trait would have been visible only in
males that's because in organisms like
Drosophila males have One X chromosome
and one Y chromosome and females have
both x chromosomes to summarize this
experiment
morgen to prove that genes are present
on chromosomes also he could find out
that the genes for eye color were
present on the X chromosome in the fruit
fly this also indicated the fact that
genes are passed from one generation to
the other
this is how Mendelian genetics as well
as such an Ambu berries chromosomal
theory of inheritance were both proved
better with Morgan's experiments
[Music]